all right a few interesting it's
interesting how the dynamics on the
david pakman show subreddit have sort of
been shifting over the last few months
we have more moderators I think the
subreddit is now over 16,000 of our
viewers and listeners participating but
the tone and tenor has changed in a lot
of ways and it seems to be getting more
pragmatic in some sense a few
interesting posts I found this morning
at david pakman.com slash read it that i
want to point out to you one is from a
user named hey there 91 who says will
you vote for joe biden if he is the
nominee presumably this is a question
for democratic party voters who may be
supporting someone other than joe biden
in the primary in their state and i my
instinct and i actually want to hear
from the audience about this my instinct
is that most democratic primary voters
understand that if you fell for the idea
in 2016 that if it's not Bernie who
cares if it's Hillary or Trump that was
a disastrous point of view and now that
we see the effect that Donald Trump has
has had and will have on geopolitical
Alliance's long after he's out of the
White House when we see the number of
judges not just to the Supreme Court but
importantly two lower courts and how
Donald Trump will have a
multi-generational impact as a result of
that I hope anybody who thought Hillary
or Trump it's sort of the same if it's
not Bernie I hope you've all been
disabused of that notion over the last
few years I know I certainly have I am
NOT going to be voting for Joe Biden in
the Democratic primary I know that Joe
Biden recently said he would consider a
Republican as a running mate that's
bonkers to me at this point in time but
if it's Biden versus Trump I'm going to
vote for Biden the judges that Joe Biden
would select would be a far cry from
those that Donald Trump has selected the
way Joe Biden would be respected around
the world even if it's not what I would
like it's not the ideal it's night and
day compared to Donald Trump so if Biden
is the nominee I will be supporting him
over Donald Trump I want to hear from
you where where is your head
on this another post by a user named
Posse Comitatus who said andrew Yang's
supposed support for medicare-for-all
has become more dubious after his more
detailed proposal has come out I read
quite a bit about this over the last 24
hours
and I am struggling with Andrew Yang's
position on health care now as many of
you know Andrew yang granted me it's
either two or three interviews he's been
on the program since he's gotten bigger
and more well known they've just been
ignoring our requests for an interview
I want Andrew yang to come back on the
program so we could talk about this I
have questions about his health care
plan he has said he has used the term
Medicare for all but also put out a plan
that does not describe anything
approaching Medicare for all I want him
back on the program I would like him
back on the program to talk about his
VAT tax and the way that it would
specifically be tardy targeted so-called
luxury goods to not be a regressive tax
I have a lot of things I want to talk to
him about I understand a lot of people
want him back on the show they are
ignoring us and listen I understand he's
getting on the Ellen show now we are
small potatoes compared to that but I
think there would be value in him coming
back on and answering these questions so
if you want to respectfully ask him and
his staffers to get him back on the show
he's welcome any time I have questions
about the health care plan and many
other things I would love to discuss
with Andrew yang lastly a user named nug
Wrangler posted to the subreddit debate
was David a beta during the elevator
incident so on the bonus show on Monday
I told a story of something that
happened in an elevator at Paris Charles
Charles de Gaulle Airport on Sunday when
I was flying back from Paris and this
has created a rift in the David Pakman
show community was I an alpha Chad
vite by virtue of how I handled the
situation or was I a beta and nug
Wrangler says I contend that David did
not tuck and run a beta would have
actually stayed I argue that David Act
like a Chad strutting through the
elevator the full elevator all the way
from the back whilst being weighed down
by pounds of luggage
I believe my behavior in the Charles de
Gaulle Airport elevator was alpha I do
and if this is at all interesting to you
become a member and then listen to the
December 30th bonus show and judge for
yourself
join the discussion as more than 16,000
of our viewers and listeners already
have at the David Pakman show subreddit
find it at david pakman.com slash reddit